deutschland fragt sich was passiert
mittwoch letzte woche hat erheblichen
zoff gegeben wissen sie schon für welche
maßnahmen sie sind ganz klar wird es
dort entscheidungen geben auch sehr
klare die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten diskutieren gerade
viel miteinander und auch mit der
bundesregierung wir haben ja jetzt
bewusst ein weg gewählt wo es jetzt
erstmal ein vorschlag von den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten gibt er wird uns
sicher morgen erreichen
aber eins ist schon klar ist wird
angesichts der erfolge die wir mit den
maßnahmen im november haben nicht
reichen wir haben eine verbesserung der
situation hinbekommen aber nicht genug
und deshalb wird es schon auch um
verlängerung gehen